[Music]
we all have different body types and
what works for my body doesn't work for
the next person it works for that person
doesn't work for me I truly just do the
best I can do for my body because I know
that I'm not going to ever have those
curves and that as and that waistline
that's just not my body and I'm fine
with that Chrissy Teigen keeps it real
when it comes to her body hi when he
jack in the box and we couldn't love her
more for it the star has snapchatted the
struggle of squeezing into a too-tight
jumpsuit proudly showing off her stretch
marks on Twitter and she even got candid
with ET about slipping into a Sports
Illustrated swimsuit not long after
giving birth to baby Luna I was the kind
of person that was you know pre-baby I
weighed myself three times a day I knew
how much I weighed at 8am I knew how
much I was supposed to weigh at 1pm and
I knew how much I was supposed to weigh
at 8a or 8pm and for me to really lose
that and not have to think about that
and just think about your body shape but
your and your curves like every time
some little girl gets to look in this
issue and see so many different audio
types and and watches a show like girls
and sees so many different body types
embracing themselves that's really
important
you